[Applause]
more than three minutes to play in the
court llama can defend well you meant
the thing but try to stop to the left in
the advantage camps in the second
quarter 710 Chicago 3:12 good traffic
then it gets a nice shot good pass by
the way the bronze strong to lose
opportunity put three point for our
rocket mortgage engineered to amaze cut
catch and schools
[Applause]
LeBron against zipser Ont that screen
from jr. waiting traffic to clarity's of
traveling
[Music]
the Cavaliers have it LeBron goes right
at the rookie takes his time in stores
Ron coming down and over control that's
what they need in trouble over there
finds the bailout play LeBron James
Robert needs it at stick shift
[Applause]
by just greater did a good job and
limited duty on them in the first half
never steal because the pressure breed
junior could use one Thompson force the
momentary switch that Lopez has picked
up three LeBron he gets marketed the way
turn the corner got it back off to the
flexion our ATT high-speed replay is the
runs flipped it to the waiting hands of
Jae Crowder body weight under control
the other ducks inside hit the bottle in
the backboard
Harris by Dwyane Wade
here comes Jeff Green Openbravo soon
when he really excels officials again
try to clean that up to the point of
death this is River though that's two or
three years inside
the Viceroy point forward point guard
point center point quarterback foot good
hustle by low LeBron James back in down
takes his time
I'm coming down just controlling the
ball can't stop in there you're too
little
you can't stop him when he gets a
shoulder by you he's drawn a lot more
attention LeBron to a rolling Kevin
laughs good read look at this nice read
here yeah I've done a good job to serve
in the florida coming back but instead
of standing still what does he do he
died little cuts to the basket move
without the ball that's a beautiful
thing